hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt seit
unserer letzten und vorletzten messe
gibt es bereits meinen eigenen back
rahmen und wer mich kennt und mich auch
schon länger verfolgt weiß natürlich
dass ich schon seit vielen jahren mit
back rahmen backes stadt mit spring
formen um genau zu sein seit etwa acht
jahren also seit dem ich verheiratet bin
da habe ich mir zuerst einmal diesen
ersten back rahmen gekauft und es gibt
natürlich ganz viele vorteile
warum ich dir eben auch benutze und zwar
kamen sowieso benutzt man die überhaupt
mit back rahmen kann man eben ganz
normal backen wie eben mit üblichen
spring formen oder auch mit blechen auch
der vorteil ist nur dass du eben ohne
boden wächst das heißt du hast nicht so
im springform boden kannst du durch viel
schneller backen und die theke gehen zum
beispiel auch viel gleichmäßiger auf und
bei den eckigen programme finde ich
sogar auch ganz gut dass wir immer so
schöne ecken hat und nicht wie es auf
einem backblech diese rundungen außen
hat das heißt man kann richtig tolle
torten und kuchen backen und braucht
eben auch nur dieses eine produkt weil
man eben nicht in der springform backen
muss und später den tortenring verwendet
für die creme sondern hat ein produkt
für alles und jetzt habe ich meinen
eigenen parkraum mittlerweile aus
verschiedenen gründen
ich habe schon mit ganz vielen
verschiedenen ba kamen und dort bringen
gebacken viele ausprobiert und natürlich
gab es bei jedem produkt auch immer
vorteile aber auch eben nachteile aber
es gab bisher noch kein einziges produkt
wo ich gesagt hab mensch der bündelt
jetzt alle vorteile in einem und das
habe ich jetzt eben mit meinem eigenen
back rahmen geschaffen und möchte ich
ihnen heute auch vorstellen ein bisschen
was zur geschichte erzählen und
natürlich auch den umgang und die pflege
auch zeigen
debug rahmen und schottenring die werden
zu 100 prozent in deutschland
hergestellt
nämlich bei uns in der region das ist
wirklich nicht weit von uns weg nur 30
kilometer und den hersteller habe ich
auf der messe kennengelernt habe mich
bisher mit ihm unterhalten
vor einiger zeit und haben gefragt
mensch kann ich vielleicht meine ideen
und meine wünsche mit einbringen und so
haben wir ihn kennen gelernt unterhalten
und dann erzählen
dieses produkt entstanden ich möchte ich
euch mal ganz kurz zeigen
ich war nämlich in der produktion habe
ein bisschen was für euch mitgefilmt und
möchte euch jetzt zeigen wie man die
einzelnen produkte auch herstellt das
hier ist jetzt der eckige back rahmen
der 7 5 cm hoch und besteht aus vier
teilen
und zwar kann man die ganz einfach
auseinander schäden hat auch den vorteil
mit der reinigung dass man den einfach
komplett reinigen kann und jetzt zeige
ich euch zuerst einmal wie sie
hergestellt sind das sind alles also
egal ob ist eckig oder 100 orten ring
die werden alle aus 100% edelstahl
hergestellt und auch das material stammt
aus deutschland
das habe ich hier diese zwei teile das
sind die innenteile und bei denen ist es
so dass es edelstahl geschliffen wird
damit man sich eben auch nicht verletzen
kann und damit man keine scharfen
außenkanten mehr hat
und so werden alle teile abgeschliffen
und die außenteile gehen dann noch eine
station weiter und zwar wird dort diese
schiene gebogen und dann auch gepresst
und damit aus den edelstahlplatten einen
rechtwinkligen back rahmen werden kann
müssen noch die teile abgeschaltet
werden
im prinzip ist der bug haben jetzt schon
fertig jetzt müssen die vier
einzelteilen nur noch zusammengesetzt
und verpackt werden
und diesen eckigen backen verwendet man
jetzt wie gesagt wie ein ganz normales
backblech muss eben den vorteil dass man
schneller backen kann und es gibt dann
natürlich noch andere vorteile
also zuerst einmal nimmt man diesen bug
rahmen und setzt ihn auf ein backblech
ich hab s und perforiert das blech und
zwar dass ganz viele kleine löcher
besteht aus aluminium
aber der zeit lassen wird auch hat noch
unsere edelstahl backblech herstellen
auf dem man eben auch super backen kann
da verwendet man am besten den bug folie
damit oder ein backpapier und kannst
dann draufsetzen und dadurch dass dieses
backblech löcher hat kommt eben die
hitze viel besser durch ich kann
schneller packen und auch gleichmäßiger
packen
jetzt kann man den bug kam auf die
gewünschte größe einstellen also
entweder lässt man ihn so ganz klein
oder man kann ihn auch auf die pose des
blechs ausziehen und dadurch dass der
hier diese durchgängige china hat ist er
eben auch sehr stabil und behält auch
seine rechtwinklige form bei meinen
alten pac haben sich verwendet hatte
hatte man hier nur diese klammer und
dadurch wurde praxis der bug rahmen nur
punktuell zusammengehalten
was natürlich weniger stabil war als
jetzt diese durch gegen die schiene
und was meint im vergleich auch ganz
deutlich sieht ist dass die anderen bug
kamen alle sehr dünnes material haben
also da wird auch an material gespart
und wir haben es hier darauf geachtet
dass dieses innenteil 1 mm stark ist und
das außen teil 0 7 millimeter das heißt
es wirklich auch richtig richtig schwer
wenn man hoch hebt sehr stabil und
bleibt natürlich auch auf dem backblech
gut sitzen
man könnte den bug haben auch auf ein
normales backblech setzen
allerdings hat man da den nachteil dass
man eben nicht dieses perforierte
backblech hat und viele backbleche haben
das problem dass sie nicht gerade sind
und der ba kam da nicht auffliegen würde
und dann der flüssige teig auslaufen
würde
jetzt zeige ich euch nur die
besonderheit des torten rings und zwar
habe ich den einmal in sieben zentimeter
höhe und einmal in zehn zentimeter höhe
der für zehn zentimeter eignet sich
wirklich super für hohe torten wie zum
beispiel eine schwarzwälder kirschtorte
oder eine käse sahne torte oder jeder
andere torte hier gerne hoch zubereiten
möchte natürlich könnt ihr auch flache
retorten drin zu bereiten und der kleine
ist super für zb den russischen
zupfkuchen 1
an rührkuchen oder zum beispiel und
bienenstich das besondere an beiden
orten ringen ist dass sich hier vorne
diesem claim hebel haben das jetzt
gerade verschlossen
den kann man ganz einfach öffnen indem
man hier einmal mit dem finger betätigt
und dann kann man den tortenring in die
gewünschte größe öffnen hier hinten noch
die klammer verstellen und dann ganz
einfach wieder schließen und so behälter
eben die form und die größe und
verrutscht nicht denn mich das ganz oft
passiert mit meinen alten torten ringen
die hatten diesen claim hebel nicht das
ist übrigens auch patentiert und da war
es ebenso ich habe es auf die gewünschte
größe eingestellt und gerade bei so
kleineren größen wie zwölfte hier ist
der ring immer wieder aufgesprungen und
man konnte den gar nicht so richtig
fixieren und deswegen ist es wirklich
ganz praktisch dass man hier jetzt
diesen klemm hebel hat bei den
tortenring ist es natürlich auch so dass
die edelstahlteile sommer geschliffen
werden damit die scharfen kanten weg
sind und man sich nicht verletzen kann
und dann werden die teile zurechtgebogen
also aufgerollt
dieser claim hebel da vorne wird separat
hergestellt und dann werden alle teile
zusammengeführt montiert und später eben
verpackt
die token ring verwendet ihr jetzt
genauso wie den bug rahmen also ihr
nehmt jetzt dafür dass florierte
backblech am besten und dann entweder
eine back folie oder ein backpapier bei
der bug folie ist es so die nehme ich
immer ganz gerne wenn ich festere teig
gehabt denn die back folie kann ich
mehrmals benutzen und musste nicht
wegschmeißen
jetzt nehme ich den tortenring und
stelle ihn auf die gewünschte größe ein
und wenn ich jetzt einen festen rührteig
zum beispiel haben würde ich das jetzt
hier rein füllen oder auch an den festen
teig würde ich ihn auch hier rein füllen
aber bei flüssigeren zeigen nämlich
immer ganz gerne backpapier und schlagt
die torten ringe damit ein
denn ansonsten können die teile ein
bisschen auslaufen
also ein bisschen dürfen am rand immer
auslaufen aber bei richtig flüssigen
zeigen es ist wirklich besser man
schlägt sie ein und zwar nimmt mal ein
bogen papier und da eignet sich am
besten ein backpapier was nicht zu glatt
ist also was so eine kleine musterung
hat dandyhaften einfach besser und die
lassen sich auch besser um die
tortenring geschlagen jetzt wird mit
einem handelsblatt papier eingeschlagen
und die andere hand hält den bug ring
fest also zuerst einmal einig das
erleichtert das ganze ein bisschen und
jetzt ganz eng bomm herumschlagen
den tortenring immer wieder mit drehen
gerne auch mal zwischendurch ein
bisschen falken
und am ende so in sich rein bringen und
dann sollte es fest sein
jetzt kann man diesen tortenring mit dem
backpapier einfach aufs backblech setzen
und so auch richtig flüssige teil
gebacken
der vorteil vom tortenring ist dass ich
nur dieses eine produkt habe das heißt
ich brauche keine springform mehr denn
ich kann den teig in diesem tortenring
backen und später war auch die torte mit
der creme befüllen
ich habe die kürzere bauzeit durch das
perforierte backblech und durch das
backen ohne boden
und vielleicht kennt ihr das auch das
manchmal torten und kuchen teige immer
so einen hügel bekommen haben und
einfach aufreißen und es passiert in
torten ringen einfach nicht mehr weil
sie eben gleichmäßig hoch backen
also soviel letzten gebrauch der torten
ringe und back rahmen was die pflege
betrifft als ihr könnt die natürlich in
die spülmaschine stecken weil sie zu 100
prozent aus edelstahl bestehen der auch
frostfrei ist aber ich mache meistens
sogar so dass ich sie mit der hand war
jetzt einfach sehr schnell geht oder ich
meistens mache ich so dass ich eben so
ein tortenring messer nehme und den
gebackenen kuchen dann auch so
herauslösen und falls ich dann aber noch
reste habe kann man die ganz gut mit dem
tortenring messer auch bisher abkratzen
also gerade jetzt die unten dann am rand
und den rest kammer einweichen und eben
mit hand spülen
das tortenring messer und die back
rahmen und torten ringe sind alle zu 100
prozent in deutschland hergestellt
genauso wie die verpackung nämlich da
was mir auch ganz wichtig dass die eben
auch hier designt ist und hier gedruckt
ist wobei sie sind wichtig ist dass es
100 prozent in deutschland gemacht ist
aber es kann ja auch im nachbarland
seien jedenfalls da wo eben die
mitarbeiter fair bezahlt werden und eben
auch entlohnt werden und da legen wir
eben nicht nur bei den produkten sondern
auch bei der verpackung viel vertrauen
schaffen natürlich bei jedem produkt
euro genau aber nach was genau versuchen
wir natürlich auch umzusetzen
ja ich glaube jetzt habe ich so ziemlich
alles gesagt sie back rahmen und torten
ringe gibt es bei mir im shop oder auch
bei globus als den globus supermärkten
zu kaufen
da könnte sie dann auch vor ort
anschauen und spart euch zum beispiel
auch die versandkosten also nicht weil
er mit dem baumarkt genau abwägen
nußbaum ablaufen und ich glaube so
ziemlich alles gesagt oder sowohl stopp
sagen so sein
dafür stehe ich mit meinem namen das
nicht aber dafür steckt also hinter der
qualität kann ich echt stehen ja und ich
hoffe dass ich euch jetzt einige fragen
beantworten konnte euch ein paar tipps
zum gebrauch geben konnte und ihr seht
ihr die back rahmen und torten ringe
immer in meinen videos in gebrauch falls
sie aber doch fragen habt könnt ihr mir
gerne schreiben und ich wünsche euch auf
jeden fall ganz viel spaß falls ihr es
euch zu legen wollte und ja zum nächsten
mal
das war es schon macht also auf
wiedersehen fotos live.de